time now for CBS morning's deals where
we share items that might help make your
day a little bit brighter a little bit
better all at exclusive low prices to
start shopping right now scan the QR
code on your screen there it is upper
left or visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle
host Gail bash joins us now I'm very
excited for this segment you got a
charger to kick us off oh yeah I do I
love all the things here but it's about
power right now this has a lot of power
this is a power bank that could charge
your laptop and your phones and if you
use it for your phones you could do it
multiple times with this thing and it
does have an outlet you can't plug it
into an outlet on the back but even if
you don't have a wall outlet you can
still use this I love it because right
there now just sitting on top of it yes
it is a wireless charger and what's
great about it is look at it it's got a
screen if you can see if you look on
your screen right there it has a digital
readout so you can see how much battery
life you have have left I love this and
this is one I'm not going to travel
without yeah and it has multiple
Chargers on it so it has C and usba yes
that's amazing it's amazing and it's not
too heavy right that's what I like that
is Magic what's happening that is Magic
what's happening right now it is the
best price on that one I love the deal
on this we have it for 38 off we have it
for 49.99 okay this is a must-have CBS
deals for yourself okay give it to
yourself like an octopus you said a
phone mount yeah it does look like an
octopus it's called tentacle and watch
this I'm going to lift this up to show
you how strong it is if you want to take
pictures with your group like attach it
to Glass a glass attach it to the wall
let's say you're a content creator this
is the thing you want to use you could
also use it in your car how much how
much does it go oh this is 29 we have it
for 33 off I really love it and not only
if you're a content creator I'm going to
put this in my car and on my buttons
Could It Go in the car my mountain bike
look at how it contorts itself like an
octopus something for home chefs this
would be YouTube
oh yeah what do we got here this pick
this up this is so lightweight this is
from Phantom Chef this is a
aluminum but it's lined with ceramic
this is a dutch oven that's very light
to hold I can hold it with my pinky this
is probably let me wait wait wait let me
see you hold that with your well we
don't have it she said she could hold it
with her Pinky Okay and she's holding it
with her okay you cannot do that
normally with those cast iron Ducks you
cannot usually do that with yeah you got
soup in there it feels dangerous but you
got little kids walking around what's
the price on this the price on this is
four it starts at 49.99 my boyfriend
said don't come home without one oh 49.
yeah yeah very good Gale bass thank you
very much of course we do partner with
these companies to get you the deals we
just mentioned to buy anything you saw
on your screen scan that QR code or head
over to cbsdeals.com to start shopping
and that'll do for us